[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ضيفنا الليل ارتبط اسمه بواحده
من اكثر القصص غرابه وفراده وماساويه اذ
شهدت حياته في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انقلابا كبير من حال الى حال ولد الدكتور
سامي العريان في الكويت عام
1958 لعائله فلسطينيه هاجرت من يافا الى
غزه وصولا الى الكويت ثم خرجت الاسره
منتصف الستينات الى مصر وهناك اكمل دراسته
وتفرج في المدرسه الثانويه متفوقا في
العام 1975 توجه الى الولايات المتحده
للدراسه الجامعيه والتي استقر فيها اربعين
عاما قبل ان يتم ابعاده عن البلاد بعد
قضيته الشهيره درس العلوم الكهربائيه
وهندسه النظم في جامعه جنوب وحصل على
درجتي الماجستير والدكتوراه من جامعه
كارولاينا الشماليه عام 85 وعيون كاستاذ
في جامعه جنوب فلوريدا قبل ان ينتقل الى
تمبل تراس نشط في الحركه الاسلاميه
الولايات المتحده حتى العمق ووصل به الامر
ان كان لاعبا رئيسيا ومؤثرا كبيرا على
صناعه القرار في البيت الابيض ابان رئاسه
جورج بوش الابن في القضايا التي تخص
المسلمين هناك لكن احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر وما سبقها من عمليات التحرير ضد
المسلمين وما تلاها قلبت احوال الرجل راسا
على عقب في هذه الحلقه نتعرف على سيرته
وسيره القضيه الاشهر والتي استمرت سنوات
انتهت بترحيله عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه دون ادانه او جريمه الدكتور
سامي العريان ضيف المقابله في الجزء الاول
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله دكتور ابدا من البدايه كعادتنا
في المقابله انت من مواليد الكويت
في عام 58 صحيح صحيح انا ولدت في الكويت
عام 58 لابوين فلسطينيين يعني والدي كان
من مواليد يافا عام 25 وجدي من مواليد
القدس 1892 جدي كان من ضمن الجيش العثماني
الذي قاتل في اوروبا في الحرب العالميه
الاولى وولدي كان من ضمن ايضا الجهاد
المقدس اللي كان يقودها فيصل الحسيني وكان
من اخر من خرجوا من يافا ولي عم ايضا
استشهد في حرب ال 48 في شمال فلسطين وخرج
ولدي وبعدها بعد الهجره يعني ووالده ايضا
من يافا وهي من العائله يعني تنسب الى عمر
بن الخطاب التاجي الفاروقي
وكانت الهجره الى الى غزه الم تكن من يافا
الى الكويت من يافا الى غزه الى غزه نعم
وهو والد يجلس في غزه وكان يشتغل في
الاونروا
وكان يشتغل في كمحاسب في الاونروا ثم
انتقل الى الكويت عام 55
تزوج عام 56 وانا ولدت 58 تعرف هذه الرحله
رحله كثير من الفلسطينيين بعد النكبه خاصه
الى الكويت
وصفت كثيرا الروائيان وادبيا صحيح كثير من
الفلس طبعا الكويت كانت وقتها يعني تخرج
من الانتداب او الاستعمار البريطاني
وتحاول ان تجلب كثير من العماله العربيه
وكان هناك كثير من الفلسطينيين الذين
اتجهوا الى الكويت للعمل هناك وكان والدي
من ضمنهم ونحن نعرف يعني عائلات كثيره جدا
جلست واستوطنت يعني مثلا عبد المحسن
القطاني الذي اصبح الكويتيا هو ابن خالد
ولدي يعني كان كثير اصبحوا كويتيين ايضا
وكثير اطباء معروفين ومشهورين كانت بيئه
فلسطينيه
مكتمله في فتره طويله من الفترات وكانت
احياء باكملها من الفلسطينيين يعني احنا
كنا نسكن في حوالي حوالي كلها كانت
فلسطينيه
كم عشت في الكويت ثمان سنوات ثمان سنوات
الاولى للاسف الشديد والدي لم يكن منتميا
فصائليا
وحاولت بعض الجهات ان توظفه ليكون
جاسوسا على الفلسطينيين وهو رفض وجاءت
حمله تفنيشات في 66 وهذا كان يعمل كان
محاسب في وزاره التربيه
ويعني
انتقلنا من الكويت عام 66 الى مصر كان
مسيسان الوالد هو كان يعني هوي ناصري
الهوى وقومي كالاخرين وطبعا الموضوع
فلسطين كان دائما حاضرا يعني حاضرا في
البيت حاضرا مع الاصدقاء حاضرا في كل مكان
انت نشات واذا تسمع اي شيء كل شيء يكون عن
فلسطين لم تنشا في اسره ذات جذور الخاليه
الاسلاميه على الاقل لا لا يمكن ان اقول
ذلك نعم ولكن يعني هناك التزام مبدئي
بمبادئ الاسلام ولكن ليس هناك
بمعنى الاسلام السياسي الذي نفهمه اليوم
ماذا تذكر عن حياتك في الكويت لم تكن
طويله
نعم كانت
سعيده كنت في
مدرسه الجميل وهي مدرسه يعني فيها كل
الجنسيات وكنت وكانت متفوقه كنت متفوقا
وحتى انني يعني سبقت يعني انتهيت من الصف
الثالث في الكويت وذهبت الى مصر للصف
الخامس
وكانه هذا ثاني انتزاع من الكويت الى مصر
مره الاولى كانت من فلسطين الى وادي حاله
الفلسطيني يعني كل حياتي كانت عباره عن
انتقال
يعني من فلسطين الى الكويت الكويت الى مصر
مصر امريكا امريكا
ما قبل النكسه بسنه في الفوره الناصريه
مصر كانت تقود العالم العربي في تلك الفس
صحيح وانا اذكر مع انه كان عمري ثمان
سنوات كمان انتقلنا في شهر تسعه 66 وهو
الشهر الذي اعدم فيه صيف قطب وهي مساله
كانت يعني
حدثها قرات عنها او صغيره طبعا انا لم
افهم يعني ثمان سنوات ماذا تفعل لكن
الصوره قالت ولكن نعم يعني اذكر تماما
كانت موجوده في في البيوت بهمس يعني ان
انه هذا اليوم كان يوم اعدام سيد قطب يعني
اذكر ذلك
اقامتكم في مصر
كانت صعبه انا اول مره شفت والدي يبكي
لانه احنا في اول يومين نسمع الانتصارات
وسقوط طائرات
يعني ذهبنا الى القدس ثم يعني تصدم بان
القدس قد سقطت واول مره اشوف ابيه
تاثرا كبيرا نعم ماذا يكون عليه
الفلسطينيه حينما يكون في الكويت او يكون
في مصر او يكون في اي مكان اخر كيف تتشكل
الهويه الفلسطينيه والهويه الفلسطينيه
حاضره وبارزه بقوه عند الفلسطينيه يعني
اهتمامه انتمائه اهتمامه عفوا والتزامه
الكبير حتى لهجته ثقافته يعني واضحه بشكل
بشكل جليل كيف يتشكل في في بلدان المنفذ
وان كانت ليست بلدان منفى بلدان العربيه
يعني على صله وثيقه بفلسطين انك هي كارثه
وهذه الكارثه جمعت الفلسطينيين يعني انت
لما تتحدث عن
الذكرى
الفلسطينيه هي كلها تجمعها هذه الكارثه
يعني لم يحدث في التاريخ الحديث على الاقل
انه 60% من الشعب يقتلع من ارضه في ضمن
شهور شهور 600 700 الى 800 الف يقتلعوا من
ارضهم ثم يشتتوا لم يحدث هذا اين حدث 60%
من الناس في ظرف شهور وكلهم عندهم الامل
بان يرجعوا ويعودوا ثم يعني يتضح ان هذا
الشراب هذا وهم
وهو يستنكر استخدام مصطلح النكبه يراه
مصطلحا مخففا
ان النكبه المستخدمه عربيه انا مجرى تطهير
عرقي يعني شيء اقسى بكثير من ان يسمى او
يوصف بالنكبه صحيح هو طبعا هذا يعني اسم
تاريخي واصبح اسم عالمي كالانتفاضه وغيره
ولكن يا كارثه الحقيقه كارثه على الشعب
وطبعا بتوصيفها العلمي الاكاديمي الدقيق
هو تطهير عرقي لا شك يعني هذه المساله
اصبحت مجمعه عليها باي حياه يعيشها
الفلسطيني يعني حينما يعيش في الكويت او
يعيش في مصر ويعيش حياته ثم تحياه كويتيه
حياه مصريه حياه سوريه حياه لبنانيه وحياه
خاصه بالفلسطينيين كطفل كيف كيف مزجت بين
بين هذين الامرين تحديدا
هو حياه يعني حياه معاناه حقيقه وعدم
انتماء يعني انت كفلسطيني تحس انك يعني في
شيء ينقصك مفهوم الامان الذي موجود عند
الكويتي في الكويت او المصري في مصر او
السوري في سوريا او اللبناني في لبنان او
العراق في العراق او بقيه الاوطان غير
موجود عند الفلسطيني الفلسطيني في اي وقت
ممكن ان يطرد من هذا البلد وهذا ما حدث
لنا اصلا انا حدث معي اكثر من مره يعني
حدث معي في الكويت
وبالتالي هذا الاحساس بعدم الامان بعدم
الانتماء هو دائما ملازم للفلسطيني
وبالتالي روحت في فلسطين بالاضافه الى
الظلم الذي وقع عندما تسمع كل هذه القصص
التي حدثت لجدك وجدتك
ولوالدك ووالدتك وعمك وعمتك وخالك وخالتك
وكل الاقرباء وتسمع قصه وراء قصه وراء قصه
من هذا من هذه المعاناه ومن هذه التضحيات
التي قدمت هذه يعني تتاصل في نفسها تكون
جزء من شخصيتك انت تنمو
وتحس بهذا الاحساس وبهذا الالم وهذه قصه
تسمعها من الصغر انت تسمعها قبل يعني ان
تتعلم اي شيء تسمع هذه القصه انك انت من
فلسطين وهذا ما حدث بك وهذه ما حدث في
يافا وفيهم الفلاني انا بسبع رصاصات ثم
يكشف والدي عن ظهره وتشوف انه نصه طاير
ايش كيف صارت
ثم يذكر لك القصه ثم يذكر قصه اخيه وكيف
استشهد كل هذه انت تنشا بها وتصبح جزء من
شخصيتك جزء من انتمائك جزء من تصورك
للعالم ما اثر عدم ولادتك في فلسطين وعدم
عيشك فيها وعدم رؤيتك لها
وحضورها الطاغي بقصصها باحداثها
بالتاريخها بماساتها بشكل كبير يعني ثمه
تشعر كانه في مسافه بين الله انت طبعا
يعني تشعر بفلسطين بدون ان تراها او ان
تعيش فيها انا انا كان لي زياره في فلسطين
وانا كبير طبعا كنا نزوره واحنا صغار في
غزه ولكن ما تذكر ثلاثه واربعه وخمس سنوات
ولكن ايضا زياره للقدس سته وستين يعني
عفوا 64
ولكن عام 83 كان عمري 25 سنه ولففت فلسطين
كلها وذهبت الى يافا وذهبت الى عكا لانه
وقتها علي خاله تعيش فيه كان طبعا اسرائيل
واحده لكن في هذه الحجوز الحواجز التي
تراها اليوم
فجاءني تصريح من خالتي وذهبت في رمضان
وكان معي زوجتي واطفال الصغار ولا اخذنا
التاكسي ولفيت فلسطين كلها حتى وقتها اذا
تذكر كان في الغزو اللبناني عام 82 فما
كان في حتى حدود فانا تجاوزت الحدود الى
كل فلسطين وتجاوزت الحدود وذهبت الى لبنان
حتى اوقفي وين رايح يرجع
انا رايت بلد الحقيقه يعني يعني اجمل
البلاد التي يمكن ان ان تراها في حياتك مع
كل ايضا هذا الاحساس الطاغي اللي كان لديه
مع
نظرتك الى هذا الاحتلال مع انك ترى انه في
هذا الشارع كان يقتل ما وقع عليك وعلى
اسرتك انت وانت يعني رجل كبير اعشاب يعني
متزوج لديك ارض فلسطين للمره الاولى في
حياتي والله يعني مشاعر مختلطه الشعور
الاول طبعا هو يعني يزداد حبك الى فلسطين
وانتماءك لها واسرارك على ان هذه ارضنا
ويجب ان تعود ثم يعني تنظر الى حجم
الماساه الكبيره ان هؤلاء الغرباء هم الذي
اصبحوا يقتنون هم الذين يسبحون هم الذين
يتحكمون فيها يتملكونها وبالتالي يكون
عندك اصرار حقيقي انه لا بد لهذا الصراع
ان ينتهي بانتصارك انت وبالذهابهم انت في
اي مدينه امضيت وقت الاكثر في فلسطين لا
ما كان عندي الحق طبعا في غزه وخان يونس
ولكن لم يكن عندي الوقت او او السماح بان
اكثر من الزياره في يوم واحد يعني زياره
تاخذ فيها كل الساحل من يافا
انتبات مثلا هناك
ليس بسهوله يعني ولكن ويوم اخر في الضفه
من نابلس وجنين
وطول كاري
والخليل
والقدس طبعا الخليل وقتها كان في بدايات
تقسيم الزماني والمكاني الذي يتحدثون
اليوم يريد ان يفعلوها في الاقصى فكان ذلك
في ذلك الوقت تصلي الظهر يجب ان تذهب لانه
بعد ذلك الوقت هو
للمستوطنين اليهود فمساله كانت قاسيه
الحقيقه 66 ماذا عن حياتك المصريه بعد 66
والله الحياه يعني في مصر تشكلت لدي
تقريبا شخصيتي الثقافيه لانه في مصر بدات
التقي بشباب
نعم وبدانا يعني
نسال الاسئله الكبرى في الحياه
وكنت اقرا يعني كثيرا جدا يعني قرانا كل
الفلسفات الغربيه وتشكلت شخصيتها واعيا
الحقيقه الشباب تحيل الاسلاميين والله ليس
بالضروره لانه احنا لا لانه الاخوان
المسلمين انا لم التقي بهم في مصر الحقيقه
يعني التقيت بهم طبعا عرفنا عنهم يعني انا
نشانا ونحن نسمع عن عن الاخوان المسلمين
ولكن لم يكونوا انا في شخصين ما شفتهم في
مصر حتى الكتب التي تنسب اليهم في كتب سيد
قطب لم تكن متوفره في مصر كنا ننظر مثلا
في لبنان وارى هناك كتب سيد قطب فاجيبها
وتاخذ الجلده وتحط قصه حب حتى تعرف مصر
وقتها يعني انت مشتهين الى 74 تقريبا الى
74 كان الثانويه العامه الثانويه العامه
انتهيت والحقيقه تشكلت هنا هنا قرات
العديد من الكتب بعد السبعه وستين كانت
صدمه كبيره لنا فتشكل وعينا عن نريد ان
نفهم ماذا حدث من اهم الكتب التي قراتها
واثرت فينا كان كتاب او كتيب الحقيقه صدر
عن
توثيق الطيب وهو كاتب سوري اسمه ما بعد
النكبتين وهو يشرح يتحدث عن النكبه الاولى
عن 48
والانظمه التي كانت منتميه الى الغرب
وهزمت ثم تشكلت انظمه اخرى كانت تتحدث عن
الثوريه والاشتراكيه ورفض الاستعمار ثم
هزمت عام 67
ويتحدث عن الانطلاقه ماذا يمكن كيف يمكن
ان نفهم ماذا يمكن ان يحدث ثم بعد ذلك
طبعا تشكلت لنا
الوعي الاخر المتعلق بالاسلام الاسلام
الاسلام ليس كدين طقوسي ولكن
كحضاره كثقافه كمحضن
كفلسفه قادره على ان على ان تجيب على كثير
من الاسئله التي كانت لدينا في ذلك الوقت
وطبعا راينا ايضا انه الحركه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه التي صعدت بعد هزيمه 67 انتكست
ايضا عام 82 وتشتت عبر الاقطار
لفت لي ما قال لك هام يعني في بدايه
الثمانينات تحدث عن ضروره انخراط الحركات
الاسلاميه في العمل في الكفاح المسلح في
المواجهه مع دوله الاحتلال سناتي له من
664 يمكن القول انه الدكتور سامي تشكل
ايدولوجيه الى حد كبير طبعا اتجاه في
الاتجاه الاسلامي نعم لانه وقتها ايضا
داخل الاتجاه الاسلامي هناك اتجاهات
مسارات والله انا اشوف يعني
اسلاميا عاما احببت فكر الاخوان المسلمين
ولكن لم انتمي اليهم انتماءا مباشرا في
مصر انتميت لهم في مرحله
لاحقه
واستمرت هذه لعده سنوات ثم اكتشفت ان هناك
قصور كبير جدا في الوعي في داخل الحركه
الاسلاميه
وهذا سبب ان استقلت يعني
الانضمام 74 انتقلت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
انا خلصت 74 الثانويه العامه وكنت في يعني
كنت اقاني المصريين كنت في مدرسه متفوقين
الحقيقه وكان مجموعي قادر ان ادخل طب وهذا
كانت نيتي يعني ولكن نظرا لاني فلسطيني لم
يسمح لي ان ادخل الطب وحاولنا ندخل
الهندسه الحقيقه في داخل مصر ويعني ايضا
لم يتيسر ذلك ويمكن انا طلعت من مصر
بشتيمه يعني
واحد كان مسؤول شتمني ووالدي يعني يعني
غضب غضبا شديدا واقسم ان لن اتعلم في مصر
نظرا لهذه الشتيمه وقال لي شوف يعني
امريكا بريطانيا وجاء القبول امريكا وذهبت
في 75
كنت مصمم اني انهي بسرعه واتفوق حتى اخذ
منها وفعلا لم اكلف والدي الا السنه
الاولى بعد ذلك اخذت منحه يعني وانتهيت من
الهندسه ثلاث سنوات حتى لا اكلف والدي
درست الهندسه رغم اهتماماتك يعني الاخرى
الفكريه السياسيه على الاقل لماذا اخترتها
دائما في تلك الفتره كان يختار هذه التخصص
انه هذه الامور هذه امور انت تعملها في
وقت فراغك انما حتى يعني ليست مجال عندك
عيش اه هو طب او الهندسه يعني طبعا لو
استقبلته من امر ما استطرت لكن مختلفه
ولكن هذه هي الفكره التي كانت سائده وقتها
ان الطب هولندا هو الذي يكفيك العيش ثم
بعد ذلك تهتم بالامور الاخرى في اي ولايه
كانت انا بدايه كنت في ثم بعد ذلك في
الماجستير والدكتوراه في ثم عملت
ماذا حدث هناك الولايات المتحده يعني في
بدايه في منتصف والله يعني طبعا ذهبت على
الصعيد الاقصد الفكري والسياسي
ذهبت الى الى هذه الولايه وكنت مصمم على
اني ان انهي دراستي بسرعه شديده
وحتى استطيع ان انهي يعني وارجع التقيت
نقل الشباب حقيقه كان في بدايه شباب كويتي
ووجدت ناس يعني الحقيقه على على قدر كبير
من الالتزام الاخلاقي والاسماء اتذكره
معروفه اليوم
كان في عنده مباركة الدويله كان في في
نهايات وقته يعني ايش معنى شباب كويتيه
تحدي
الكويتي كان نشطا الاكثر نشاطا وكان عندهم
مؤسسه او او منظمه اسمها رابط شمال موسم
الكويتي
كان في سليمان شمس الدين ايضا يعني كثير
من الاخوان كانت جهه استقطاب على الاقل اي
نعم كان عندهم مخيم سنوي واستقطبنا
الحقيقه وجدت انه هناك يعني في عمل المنظم
وفكر منظم
والتزام اخلاقي وادبي
واسلاميذ
الفكر رسميا 78
لانه في اخوين كثيره
هم يمثلوا كل الاقطار
جاءت لاحقا لاحق اقصد يعني معبر عن انما
هو كان هناك في تقريبا في كل الغرب في كل
الموجود انه الاخوان اللي ينتمون على
الفكر الاخواني التنظيمات كل تنظيم له
خصوصياته ولكن بشكل عام لينتموا لهذا
الفكر
بيضمهم طبعا تظن ان انت تكون في اسره
واحده فيها كويتي فيها فلسطيني وفيها
عراقي وفيها لبناني وفيها سوري يعني
انا يعني استقلت 83
يعني حاولت تكون الخمس سنوات ماذا حدث في
الخمس سنوات الخمسه اعوام هذه
والله شوف يعني انا طبعا
يعني هذه قصص طويله لما احدث عناوينها
الرئيسيه عناوينها الرئيسيه انه كان في
تغيرات وتحولات في داخل امريكا في داخل
حركه الاخوان هناك من يريد ان يعودون مره
اخرى الى بلادهم ويريدون ان يبقوا على
السريه وهناك من استوطنوا لا يستطيعون
العوده ويريدون ان يذهبوا الى العلنيه
والى المؤسساتيه
تسمح طبعا لكن من يريد العوده يخشى يخشى
على نفسه فهذا التدافع هذا
متى بدات تاسيس تنظيم الاخوان في امريكا
الاختيار على المستوى الفكري في الستينات
في نهايه الستينات المستوى
نعم اذا تحدثنا عن رموز اسماء
كان احمد القاضي من مصر كان محمود ابو
السعود وهو عضو مكتب ارشاد سابق
نعم وفي بعض الاخوه العراقيين الذين اتوا
جمال البرازنجي يعني بعض الاخوه الاخرين
يعني توفر رحمه الله عليه هدول تقريبا
عندهم عمل طلابي وهذا العمل الطلابي تطور
وهم طبعا جايين ايضا من جذور اخوانيه تطور
الى ان انشئ التنظيمات ارجع بشكل يعني
واضح بشكل رسمي واصبح ملتحق يعني
التنظيمات التنظيم في امريكا على حسب
الجنسيه كل التحق الكل ببلاده في بلاده
نعم ولم يرجع يكون في بلده وانما في
امريكا
هل كان يكبر يتوسع طبعا هو الذي حدث انه
هذا انا التقيت شخصيات كثيره كانت منتميه
حتى وان مصرح من الواضح انها كانت منتميه
يعني هو الذي حدث طبعا زي ما قلت هذا
الصراع ادى في نهايه الامر انه هو يعني
قسم الناس الذي لا يريد ان يكون من جزء
عملي هو طبعا راح
مع بنهايه الثمانينات بمعنيات السبعينات
عفوا
جاءت قياده مختلفه كانت قياده على راسها
اخ سوداني توفى رحمه الله عليه
وتوسع التنظيم توسعا كبيرا جدا في السنتين
الثلاثه اللي بعدها
ثمانين 81 من 79 الى 82 83 تقريبا تضاعف
ثلاثه مرات
وهذا سبب ازمه لانه اتجه في الاتجاه
التاسيسي والاتجاه العلني واصبح هناك
انقلاب بعدها في داخل
الاخوه هدول
وتراجع التنظيم وقتها انا الحقيقه لما شفت
المساله اصبحت مش فكريه تدافعيه وصناعيه
انسحبت ماذا كانت العناوين الرئيسيه التي
تشغل التنظيم في امريكا مساله العلنيه
والسريه مساله المؤسساتيه والعوده في ناس
عايزين يجلسوا يعني وبالتالي بناء مؤسسات
يجب ان تكون علنيه بالنسبه لي انا الحقيقه
كان الفاصل موضوع الفلسطيني
لانه انا كنت ايضا
انشات احد المؤسسات التي تتعامل مع فلسطين
كان اسمها الاتحاد الاسلامي لفلسطين وكنت
فكرتي وقتها انه يجب ان نعمل لفلسطين من
خلال
المجموع وليس من خلال التنظيم من خلال
الناس كل العرب كل العرب والمسلمين وغير
المسلمين وغير المسلمين يعني انا وضعت
الدستور وقتها لهذه المؤسسه وكنت قاصدا ان
يكون هناك غير فلسطينيين وان يكون هناك
غير مسلمين في داخل الجنسيات كانت تستحوذ
على الاعداد الكبرى في داخل تنظيم الاخوان
في امريكا
[موسيقى]
في ذلك الوقت كان هناك طبعا الحديث عن
التربيه يعني برضو كلمه التربيه كانت
تستخدم بطريقه كان يعني بطريقه الحقيقه
رومانسيه اكثر منها لما كانت القياده في
تلك الفتره التاثير والتوجيه بشكل اكبر في
79 هو طبعا انتقلت كما ذكرت انتقلت يعني
كانت قياده اردنيه الحقيقه ما في قياده
جنسيه واحده يعني هي مجموعات يعني بس انما
تمثل فكرا واحده انما يعني كشخص كان واحد
اردني ثم انتقل الى واحد سوداني ثم انتقل
الى وهكذا يعني
[موسيقى]
منذ البدايات شغلت قضيه فلسطين موقعها
داخل الحركه الاسلاميه فشكل البلتمون الى
جماعه الاخوان في مصر وسوريا كتائب مستقله
شاركت في المعارك التي تلت النكبه وكذا
فعلت الحركات الاسلاميه الاخرى في
العالمين العربي والاسلامي
حضورها بتفاصيلها كافه لم تكن قضيه فلسطين
اولويه لدى المنضويه تحت لواء الحركات
الاسلاميه وانما كانت هما من جمله هموم
ناء بها الشارع الاسلامي من صراع مورو في
الفلبين الى قضيه كشمير بين باكستان
والهند فالاجتياح السوفيتي لافغانستان
وصولا الى اريتريا المغزوه من جارتها
اثيوبيا كانت الاهتمامات البنيويه السائده
لدى الحركات والتنظيمات الاسلاميه موجهه
لبناء المجتمعات على اسس قويه وصولا الى
خروج جيل النصر المنشود وفقا لادبياتها
لكن وعي بعض ابناء التيار الاسلامي بطبيعه
الصراع واختلاف كيان الاحتلال عن الاشكال
الاستعماريه الاخرى التي استلط بلظاها
المنطقه دولا وشعوبا دفعهم الى القول
بضروره شغل قضيه فلسطين موقعا مركزيا في
وجدان واهتمامات الحركه الاسلاميه
وابنائها وخارطه تحركاتها السي اسيه ذهب
هؤلاء الى ان حل قضيه فلسطين وانهاء
الاحتلال من شانه اي يسمى في حل جميع
القضايا الاخرى باعا وذلك بالنظر الى
الدور الذي ما فتئ الدوله الاحتلال تقوم
به من اضعاف دول المنطقه وانهاكها منذ
غرست قصرا في الجسد العربي المكلوم
[موسيقى]
لسبب متعلق بقضيه فلسطين لانه يعني كل
الشغل اللي اشتغلناه في موضوع فلسطين اصبح
عليه ارتداد يجوا اخوه كثيرين من من طلاب
فلسطينيين
ورفضوا الشعار التي كنت احمله في ذلك
ان القضيه الفلسطينيه هي القضيه المركزيه
للحركه الاسلاميه والامه هذا في ذلك الوقت
هذا الشعار كان مرفوضا عند الاسلاميين في
فلسطين لماذا هم كانوا يظنون انه في بعضهم
يقول ان الله هو الحقيقه المركزيه يعني
ايه لكن افترض الاولى ان يكون الفلسطينيين
اذكر كنت في مؤتمر كان في 120 واحد كلهم
تنظيمي يعني وقيل لي انك ستاتي وتتحدث عن
هذه الشعار وكان بجانب اخ كويتي يعني لا
اريد اذكر اسمه وتحدثت انا يعني لماذا
القضيه الفلسطينيه القضيه المركزيه من
ناحيه السياسيه تاريخيه فكريه يعني حركيه
الى اخره يمكن 45 دقيقه الاخطاء تكلم
دقيقتين وقال يا جماعه الحركه الاسلاميه
رايحه في هاي واي في اسمه فلسطين
اللي يروح الله معه احنا متجهين الى الله
وبعد تقريبا ساعتين من النقاش من 120 واحد
لم يقف معي واحده لم يقف احد
او سبحان الله بعد الانتفاضه الاولى
تقريبا كل الناس قلبت
يعني هم مشكلتهم مش مع القضيه الفلسطينيه
مشكلتهم مع ان تاخذ كل هذا الرئيسيه كانت
هي عباره عن الدوله الاسلاميه وان الدوله
جيش الجيوش وتحرر فلسطين
تقريبا هذه الفكره الرئيسيه نحن يعني
وبالتالي حجب الاسلاميون انفسهم عن
الدخول او البلوغ في القضيه فلسطين لسنوات
بسبب هذا الخلط وهذا اللبس 83 تركته تنظيم
الاخوان وين رحت والله انا ادركت وقتها
من الواضح انه في مجموعه انا قلت المشكله
وعي
وبالتالي مشكله الوعي علاجها بالحوار
وتقريبا في السنتين ثلاثه لبعضها طبعنا
يمكن طبعت يمكن 40 كتاب
كنت اشوف منطقات واطبعم اروح المؤتمرات
ونعمل بس حوارات لاني قلت المشكله هنا
فكريه لازم نشتغل على هذه المساله من
ناحيه داخل الحركه يعني لذلك عملت يعني
شيء كثير من المقالات بما فيها كتابات
للمرحوم اسماعيل الفاروقي وغيره يعني وعبد
الوهاب وكنا نتحدث في هذا الحوارات عند
حتى يعني بدايات تقريبا الانتفاضه
وبدانا يعني ننخرط في العمل الفلسطيني على
المستوى هنا كان نشاطا فكريا نشاطا
توعويا الى اخره صحيح داخل اجواء الحركه
الاسلاميه داخل اجواء الحركه حتى
المؤتمرات اللي كنت اقودها اصبحت بس احضر
حتى اني اناقش مثل هذه المسائل لم تنتقل
الى ضفه اخرى
بمعنى بمعنى من الاخوان الى الى جماعه
انا اقل يعني وعاء يهيئ الجماعه الحقيقه
يعني انا كنت منفتح على اي اتجاه يعني حتى
الاخوان نفسهم اذا تغيروا يعني لان انا
مؤمن ان العمل المنظم مهم انه لا يمكن ان
العمل المؤسسي وعلى الاهميه هو العمل
المؤسسي هو العمل المنتج العمل الاخر هو
العمل الفكري تعمله ثم يندثر يعني لا
يستمر وبالتالي موضوع انشاء واقامه
المؤسسات كان بالنسبه لي مهمه جدا وهذا
تقريبا لا يمكن ان يفسر كثير من الامور
التي قمت فيها في امريكا ماذا درست
الدكتور في الماجستير والدكتور انا درست
الحقيقه هندسه كهربائيه في البكالوريوس
وهندسه كمبيوتر في الماجستير والدكتور
استمريت في مجال الهندسه وكان ذلك المسار
الفكري هو مسارا شخصيا حياتيا ذاتي
متوازيين
اذا ما اردت ان اتحدث عن الاشكاليه التي
تعرضت لها
والمحاكمه طويله والسجن والاعتقال هل ابدا
من 83 ام ام لاحقا لانه هم رصدون كل شيء
الحكومه الامريكيه بدات من 84
عندي شويه يعني تعرف احنا نثق بالامريكان
فاكين في شيء من 84
اغار على بيتي اخذوا كل شيء طبعا عفوا
المقصد نثق بس اقصد انه يعني سرديتهم
فلنبدا منها هم لما دخلوا على بيته مرتين
مكتوب باللغه العربيه وكذا فوجدوا بعد
الوثائق تعود الى 84 فمنها هذه الوثائق
يعني ليست يعني ليست بالخطيره التي شيء
ولكن انت عارف لانه التهمه التي ارادوا ان
يلصقوها بها تهمه التامر ففي قانون التامر
في امريكا في قضايا فنيه لا علاقه انه
ممكن عندما يختار
تاريخ معين ممكن يذهب قبله وبعده عشر
سنوات فهي مساله فنيه كانت اكثر منها
حقيقه ولكن لانه في وثيقه ممكن تكون وقتها
في الاربعه اظن 84 ايضا كانت بدايه بروزك
يمكن بشكل لافت كشعب وهو على المستوى
المحاضرات حول امريكا بدات قبل ذلك
الحقيقه يمكن من سنين يعني
في في كثير من المحاضرات التاريخ هذا
لفتني دكتور من ناحيه ثانيه انه ايضا مسار
حركه الجهاد هو شبيب المسار الذي سرت عليه
يعني العلاقه مع الاخوان المسلمين التوتر
الذي حصل عدم القناعه والايمان ثم بدايه
الثمانينات وقبلت امين عام الحركه فكان
ثمه
لا كان في طبعا دكتور الشقاقي رحمه الله
عليه والدكتور يعني
اصدقائه كان دكتور الهندي وغيره يعني نعم
طيب ماذا كان النقاش لا كان نقاش يعني حول
هذه المساله يعني وترى انك انت اقرب انهم
كانوا اقرب على الاقل وانا اقرب لهم فيها
حماس كانت متردده في هذه المساله والاخوان
بشكل عام الجهاد كان لديها ميل لمشاركه
اكبر حركه اسلاميه في المواجهه وفي النظام
وفي العمل السياسي هذا ما تبين له طبعا
وبالتالي انا لا اريد ان
يعني روايه حماس وروايه الجهاد هذه مساله
للتاريخ هو يحكم بينها ولكن
يعني قطعا ان موضوع
الدخول في المواجهه المباشره مع العدو
الصهيوني كانت عند الجهاد اقرب في ذلك
الوقت بشكل واضح وهذه المساله تغيرت فيما
بعد عند الاخوان المسلمين في في فلسطين
يعني نعم
وجدت نفسك اقرب
على المستوى نعم على المستوى الفكري في
ذلك الوقت اننا فعلا نحن نريد ان نواجه
انا لا اتحدث عن المواجهات اتحدث عن
مواجهه عسكريه الحقيقه نتكلم عن مواجهه
بكل اشكالها وانواعها وانه هذا لا يمكن ان
نترك العدو الصهيوني يعني مرتاح في هذه
المساله انضميت بشكل رسمي دكتور والله هذا
السؤال لم اجب عليه حتى الان لم تجب يعني
ان شاء الله في مذكراتي
هل هذه المساله لان اتهامك هو كان في صلب
هذه القضيه
لا شك يعني انما ايش حجم هذه العلاقات
لمست العلاقات هو مساله الدعم ومساله
التيسير
لما جاء وتعيينوا في الجامعه
وفعلا هو جاء ولا ينظر له صديق انظر لانه
طبعا طبعا ولكن اقصد انه يعني هم طبعا
تعريفهم اولا عندما جاء رمضان رحمه الله
عليه وجلس في امريكا وكان معنا وكذا هناك
الجهاد لم تكن محظوره
يعني هو جاء في التسعين تسعين هي حضرت 95
هو 95 95 وبالتالي انا منتميا لحركه
سياسيه ومقاومه ما فيها مشكله وكان اصلا
ايضا الدكتور موسى ابو مرزوق كان متحدث
رسمي وكان يعرف بانه
الناطق السياسي او انه مسؤول المكتب
السياسي وكان رايح جاي على امريكا ما في
مشكله المشكله بدات فيها يناير 95 وقتها
كان رمضان يجب ان ياخذ قرار اما ان ينسحب
او يذهب
ما الذي حدث في امريكا حتى يتحول الموقف
نشاط صهيوني منظم امشي اخر تغير الموقف من
من من حركات المقاومه الفلسطينيه لا طبعا
الصهاينه لعبوا دورا كبيرا ولكن ايضا
امريكا يعني
يعني اذا رجعنا الى سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
في نهايه التسعين 91
واصبحت امريكا هي تقريبا القطب الاوحد
امريكا اصبح عندها استراتيجيه واميره
تنتقل
في مراحل يعني خاصه مفصليه الى ما يسمى
بالاستراتيجيه العظمى
اللي كانت موجوده عند امريكا وقتها كان
عندها عده خيارات اختارت ما يسمى بالليبره
الهجومنيه يعني
الهيمنه الليبراليه على العالم
وبذاتها هذا يعني انها عندها يعني تصور
محدد للعالم واختارت اعدائها وكل قضيه
الاسلام وفوبيا ايضا نبعث من هذه المساله
انه هذا هذا العدو العدو اي انسان يريد ان
يتكلم عن استقلال او عن يعني مقاومه
الهيمنه الامريكيه واصبح حدود بشكل تلقائي
بعد سقوط المصد الرئيسي اتحاد السوفي
انتهت الحرب البارده واصبح عند قطب واحد
بذور المواجهه معه او بذور اسلام بدات
مباشره ب89 انا ممكن ارجع لها النقاش في
الحلقه الثانيه نقاشا فكريه الان النقاش
الشخصي وقتها طبعا انا كنت جزء ايضا من
هذه
الثمانينات وشفت الرايين ملتلي الرؤى
المطروحه في حركه الجهاد وضروره اشتباك
الحركات الاسلاميه وخوض المواجهه كامله
ليس بالضروره فقط المواجهه العسكريه كان
هذا ايميلك بشكل رئيسي التحول الرئيسي في
امريكا حصل بعد اصله
يعني قبلها كان هناك هامش كبير جدا ان
تتحدث احنا انا عملت خمس مؤتمرات عن
فلسطين ما بين 88 و 92 كنا نتحدث بكل شيء
واكتشفت اثناء محاكمتي انه كانت
تبعت واحد ياخذ ملخصات كامله على كل من
فعلناه يعني علني ثم يذهب به وما يعملوا
شيء ما عندهم مشكله فيه واحنا نتكلم عن
يعني يعني حتى ليس بصوت قوي ولكن حتى
بكلمات قويه جدا
حتى استخدموا لك عبارات للموت
خلينا نروح للمحاكمه دكتور لانها يعني وهي
غطيت لكن هناك جيل كامل لا يعرف عنها شيء
متى بدات القضيه وكيف شوف هو الصهاينه
استهدفوني مبكرا كانوا يحاول يطردونني من
الجامعه الذي حدث في امريكا في نظام جامعي
اذا ثبت تشتغل بعد سنه سنوات وبعد ست
سنوات تقرر الجامعه اما تثبتك او تقول لك
شوف لك شغله ثانيه انا ثبت ويثبت اصبحت
جزء من الجامعه من الصعب جدا يعني يعني
اقرب من المستحيل انهم يطردوك لانه هذه في
الحريه الاكاديميه في امريكا هذا النظام
له الان يعني اكثر من 70 80 سنه ثم الذي
يثبت يثبت يعني اخر قضيه لها
محاوله طرد استاذ في الجامعه
2002 يعني اتكلم انت على حوالي ثلث قرن
يعني لم يحدث
ومن وقتها لان لم تحدث ايضا الا فلما
يذكره في هذه المساله يذكروا
مساله كانت صعبه جدا فهم يحاولوا الصهاينه
ولم يفلحوا بعد حرب بعد الاحداث الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر وجدوا هناك فرصه كان مدخلا
عظيما مدخلا نعم وكانت رئيسه الجامعه
وقتها صهيونيه ولها حتى يعني
مش استثمارات لها تشارتي لها
في داخل فلسطين في داخل الكنب اسرائيلي
تعتبرعات لاسرائيل يعني فهي
وهذا الكلام
ظهر لنا لاحقا تقول لهم ما عندي شيء ممكن
اطرده فيه لما جاءت هذه وخرجت في مقابله
يعني يعني كانت مشهوره في في فوكس نيوز
واستهدفت فيها استهدفت بحياتي فقالوا
حفاظا على حياتك سنجمد يعني وضعك قليلا
المقابله كانت تحول ماذا والله الحقيقه
بعد الحادي عشر من سبتمبر كل يوم كنت في
الاعلام نحاول يعني ندافع قدر انا شايف
انه في اشكاليه كبيره
نعاني منها يعني
وهذه كانت احدى المقابلات ولكن كانت
مستهدفه الرجل اتهمني بالتهامات عديده انا
طبعا قبلها بعد
بعد خروج الدكتور رمضان واصبح الامين
العام واجهت مشاكل كبيره منها يعني ايضا
ايقاف عن التدريس سنتين وعملوا تحقيق وبعد
التحقيق قالوا ما في شيء ما في مشكله
بالعكس واحنا كان عندنا مركز دراسات ايضا
قالوا كل العرب تهمه كانت انك دعمت رمضان
حتى الان فلم يقع سنتين اول شيء هذه لما
جاءت قالت انا ساطردك بعتت لي انذار
بالطرد وقتها وقفت معايا كل اللقبات وكل
المؤسسات التعليميه وكل الصحف واصبحت كلها
ضد الجامعه وقالوا لها اذا لم يرجع خلال
الفصل القادم سنضعك في القائمه السوداء
خافت فارسلت لقناه طيب نعطيك مليون دولار
وتستقيل
فرئيس البورت رئيس
المجلس الامناء قال كيف انا هذا الرجل
اقول عنه ارهابي تقولي اعطيني مليون دولار
لا فذهب الى جيب بوش جيب بوش اللي هو حاكم
الولايه اللي هو اخو الرئيس
فعملوا لي قضيه في ذلك والجامعه رفعت علي
قضيه عشان تكسب الوقت ثم عملوا لي قضيه
الحقيقه يعني كانت يطلبوا فيها ثلاث مدد
مدى الحياه دائمتين سنه او امر يعني خيالي
ولكن هي كانت وكانت وظهرت في طب بس عشان
نركز الدكتور أنا المشاهد اريد ان اعيد
المواساره نعم بعد سبتمبر بدات القضيه
بشكل جدي كان في لها سوابق ايقافك فتره
سنتين الى اخره لكن لم يتم فصلك لا طبعا
لا تستطيع لم تكن تستطيع لكن بعد سبتمبر
2001 انذرتني بالفصل على اساس
ظهرت طبعا في الاعلام تدافع وكذا
وجهت
لك اتهامات لم توجه اتهامات مباشره صحفيه
لان
صحفيه اللي كانت تروج عنك كل الكلام الذي
ممكن هذا ارهابي هذا يدعو الى كذا الى قتل
كذا يدعم جماعه الجهاد وهذه اصلا يعني
بدون اي
بدون اي ادله يعني كلها عباره عن تحليلات
وعن اقوال وعن اشياء وتدار وتولاك يعني
مثلا
عمله قضيه انك كيف يغيروا على بيتي فمجرد
انهم اغاروا على بيتك هذا اصبحت تهمه يعني
مدام الاف بي اي متجهه وجايه وتاخد كل شيء
من عندك اذا انت كذا وكذا يجدوا لك مثلا
كلمه قلتها ياخذها مخارج المساق ثم يضعوها
عليك وهجوم مستمر انك انت قابلت فلان
الشيخ عمر عبد الرحمن مثلا وهذا الشهاب
متهم في كذا وكذا وهذا اذا انت لك علاقه
انك دعيت راشد الغنوشي راشد الغنوشي هذا
الرجل الارهاب اللي من تونس ان حسن
الترابي واخذ جزئيات وبناء صوره بناء صوره
طبعا انك انت العلاقه بكل هؤلاء وهؤلاء
اصلا ارهابيين وما حد يتكلم يعني راشد
الغنوشي ارهابي حسن الترابي ارهابي يعني
ولكن ما حد يسال هذه الاسئله هم بس يرموا
عليك يرموا عليك ثم اصبح هناك صوره
يحاولوا كونها ومع كل هذا لم يستطيعوا ان
لا يخلوني اسكت ولا يطردوني من الجامعه
وكان هذا بالنسبه لهم احباط كبير طيب بدات
بدات الصراع مع الجامعه
مع الجامعه لما جاءت هذه المؤسسه التي
تدافع عن حقوق اساتذه الجامعات ووضعتها
امن الامر الواقع اما ترجعيه او نضعك في
القائمه السوداء قالت لا انا
ادفع له المسؤولين الكبار قالوا لا
فاعطوها لحاكم الولايه ذهب الى اخيه
وعملوا لي قضيه يعني
وزاره العدل عملت قضيه الحقيقه كانت يعني
غير متوقعه قضيه كمستمرت
بدات القضيه في فبراير 2003
وكنت في 27 شهر قبلها قبل المحاكمه مع انه
في امريكا لك الحق انك تطلب ان تحاكم في
70 يوم هم رفضوا قالوا احنا غير مستعدين
فلفقوا اشياء كثيره جدا بس قبلها 27 شهر 2
الافرادي
يعني يعني تنتظر محاكمتك طب انتم بانتظار
المحاكمه مسجون انفرادي بانتظار بعد ذلك
تمت المحاكمه اخذت سته شهور وحتى اليوم هي
اطول المحكمه بعد الحادي عشر من سبتمبر ست
شهور متتاليه من البدايه للنهايه جابت
فيها الحكومه الثمانين شاهد
ونحن لم نعطيهم لم يعني ندعوا شهدا واحدا
ومع ذلك ما استطاع ان يدينوا باي تهمه كم
حكموا عليك بالنهايه خمس سنوات
يعني جاءت النتيجه لصالحنا فهم كنا احنا
اربعه
في اثنين خرجوا والقاضي قبل ما ينتهوا
اثنين الثانيين يعني هم براون من كثير من
التهم وقبل ان يباعوا 17 تهمه تقريبا
ثمانيه
تهمه
فمجموعنا فيه 78 تهمه انتهت ولكن قبل ما
ينتهي المحلفين بالبقيه لانه واضح وين
رايح الاتجاه القاضي طلب ان يرى فوجد 78
تبرئه وباقي البقين حوالي 22 ولا كذا يمكن
علي فيها سبعه ثمانيه راح اوقف المحاكمه
عرفوا الاتجاه عرف وين رايح الاتجاه فاوقف
المحاكمه وقال انتم ممكن كان اوريدي في في
اثنين خرجوا تبرا واصبح بعض التهام فوقتها
قال لا نعمل محاكمه الجديده اوقف القضيه
وبدات محاكمه جديده لا مع المحاكمه
الجديده اللي تم انه اتفقت معهم اوكي هم
القضيه كلها ضعفت مع 78 ما انت لازم
تركبها مؤامره انتهت المؤامره لانه انا ما
عملت شيء فجابوا واحد وواحد وواحد وركبونا
فوق بعض يعملوا مؤامره الاثنين هدول خرجوا
وين المؤامره فقالوا طيب تتنازل عن كل
حقوقك
اشهر ولا سنوات سته شهور يعني ما بين هذا
والاتفاق مع الحكومه كان حوالي ثلاث سنوات
وشوي
اتفقنا معهم ان يتنازل عن كل حقوقهم وامشي
خلاص تسقطوا كل شيء وليش قبلت انك تتنازل
والله شوف يعني والله حسيت انك بمواجهه
ظلمه
العدل في امريكا ليس مجانا ولا رخيصا انا
حتى الان حتى ذلك الوقت كنت دافع مليون
دولار
والان تبدا محاكمه جديده بدك كمان مليون
دولار لانه خلاص انتهى المحامين هذول عشان
يستمروا لازم تفعلوا من جديد جدد واصبح
واضح لدينا ان القاضي
معادي خصم فالان كثير من الامور التي يمكن
يعني
فهمها المحلفين في الماضي ممكن الان تكون
مختلفه صف لي ابرز الانتهاكات في محاكم
الدكتور سعد يعني مثلا
يتحدثون عن
[موسيقى]
المؤامره اللي احنا عملناها فيجيبوا مثلا
كلام
امثال
كان احد المتهمين او احد الاخوه اللي
معانا نتكلم لواحد
بلهجه فلسطينيه ضفاويه يقول قطايف فاروح
مترجمها الى كتائب ومحولينها الى عمليه
عسكريه وهو بيتكلم ان احنا بقول له ايش
الليله اللي عندكم بقول له عنا ليله قطايف
يعني يعني قطايف هو هذاك الاراضي كتائب
الاخ اللي سمعها ماروني لبناني سمعها
كتائب راح مترجمها
ايش كان عندهم كان
عندهم ليله كتائب بتمرن ولا مش عيب اشياء
غريبه وعجيبه انا هذا بنفس الرجل
حلم حلم في يوم من الايام ان انا بكلمه عن
فلسطين في حلمه يعني
وتحدث مع اخ تاني في شكاره وكان معنا في
القضيه عن هذا الحلم ايش قلت له انا في
حلمه هذا الحلم رويا للمحلفين كادله ضدي
فكنت بقول للمحامي طب هذا مش حلمي اصلا
يعني كيف يحاسبوني على حلم غيري وطبعا
الحلم فيه كذا وراح وعملنا وسوينا يعني
طيب ما الاشياء العادله في محاكمتك او
الاشياء التي كانت تمثل يعني وجها مشرقة
يشوف امريكا فيها ديمقراطيه
اذا ما ارادت الحكومه ان تلوثها
فيها حقوق قانونيه لو الموضوع مستمر بدون
تدخلات اخرى تسيسها وبالتالي وجودنا في في
فلوريدا الحقيقه في امور كان ما يستطيع ان
يتجاوزها القاضيه ولا الحكومه منها انه
انت عندك جوري عندك محلفين لانه انا قضيتي
كانت معروفه بنسبه حوالي 97% فكان لازم
يجيبوا ناس يغربلوهم غربله وهذه مساله
كانت شاقه جدا وتعبنا فيها جدا حتى نجيب
في الاخره 12 واحد
ولكن جبنا في الاخر 12 واحد في قضايا
تفاصيل كثيره ليس هنا مجال ذكرها لكن ثمه
وجه مشرف ولكن هذول 12 واحد في الاخر هم
الحقيقه وازنوا ما كان في تسييس مهما
حاولت الحكومه وما في الاخر قالوا الحكومه
كل كامل مش مقنع وبالتالي 12 واحد يجيبوهم
من الناس ابرياء هذه مساله مشرقه دكتور
سامي شكرا جزيلا لك ثمه التفاصيل كثيره
اخرى لها علاقه بالقضيه تدخل الرئيس
اردوغان في نهايه الامر وانتقالك الى
تركيا علاقتك ايضا البارزه والشهيره في
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جورج بيشتغل الابن
وتفاصيل اخرى لها علاقه بالمسيره الفكريه
قضيه فلسطين ورعاكم فيما يتعلق
بهذه القضيه بالانتقال من طور الى طور
اخصصها ان شاء الله لنقاش مستقل في الحلقه
القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على طيب المتابعه الاسبوع القادم
ان شاء الله مع الدكتور سعد الارياف في
الجزء الثاني من المقابله في امان الله
[موسيقى]